my colleague matt walsh has proposed a
very very difficult challenge which is
to watch this stupid psa
of hollywood liberals that's been going
around talking about
blm and the riots and all sorts of
social justice
stuff and to see how long you can
make it before the cringiness of the
entire experience overwhelms you
and threatens your life so i'm gonna
take matt up on this challenge let's
begin
i take responsibility i don't know who
that person is i do know who that guy is
that's take responsibility that's the
breaking bad
i take don't know who that is
responsibility
i take responsibility for every
unchecked moment for every time it was
easier to ignore than to call it out for
what it was
every not so funny joke is that
colin farrell every unfair stereotype
every blatant
i do know who she is she's like deborah
messing's the most liberal person ever
so who set this up as my first quit
don't know who that is i don't know who
that is that's so
the first thing that's striking me is i
don't
recognize these people julian moore i
know
black people are being slaughtered in
the streets it's not true in their own
homes
these are our brothers and sisters that
is true
brothers and sisters the part is true
but the slaughter and the systemic thing
that's not true
don't know who that is wow i'm actually
kind of
pleased watching this video because i
realize that hollywood celebrities don't
have that much
control anymore like we i don't
recognize them this guy i recognize but
i don't know his name
stereotypes no matter how big or small
obviously what they're saying is just
the
political points are just not true i
take responsibility.org like what is
that organization should be a death
sentence sleeping
in your own home should not be a death
yeah they're not death sentences playing
video games
statistics are pretty clear death
sentence shopping in a store
should not be a death sentence
business as usual should not be
life-threatening where's the music
now it's the mu i'm gonna i'm squinting
my teeth i'm getting through this i
stand against the thing that's so
useful wow so brave wow i thought you
i thought you were for hate hate i
didn't real but you're against hate
that's courageous and killer cops must
be prosecuted they are
murderers okay stop stop this is it this
is it this is actually
the most dispiriting part of it because
aaron paul is his name the guy from
breaking bad
he's usually a he's a pretty good actor
as far as i can tell
this performance not very convincing the
the melodrama
and you know why it's because when you
when you act you're supposed to
behave truthfully in imaginary
circumstances these circumstances are
just so ridiculous they're trying to
pass the imaginary circumstances off as
true
this this idea that you know there's
this white supremacy that's slaughtering
innocent black americans all over
america just isn't the case
so they're they're tilting at windmills
right they're they're just going after
this allegedly widespread ku klux klan
right in the country that just that just
doesn't exist
but i guess the silver lining in this
storm cloud of cringiness
is what influence do they have they're
now just the
objects of ridicule how long did i make
it in that video how did i
i made it like two two minutes did i was
it two minutes or one minute
one for 148 is pretty good i beat matt i
want to see how long you can make it
use the hashtag walsh challenge let's
see if you can go as far as i did
[Music]
you